then that gets to the words which which
show a fairly gutsy action from Richard
Sherman calling out the owners you know
we touched on yesterday as it relates to
the Arizona Cardinals and Kliff
Kingsbury saying that he supports his
guys if they protest during the anthem I
said it needs to come from hiring the
organization it needs to come from the
owners Sherman's point where are the
owners in all of this why haven't the
owners spoken why are some of them so
quiet he said it's not pulling them like
it is the rest of the country because if
it was then they'd speak Jerry Jones
especially has no problem speaking up
any other time about anything else but
when it's such a serious issue and he
could really make a huge impact on it
with a few words his silence speaks
volumes that is an extremely accurate
statement by Richard Sherman it's an
appropriate observation and look when we
talked about in the context of coaches I
was reluctant to say they all should
speak up but where we are right now
especially on the heels of what Roger
Goodell did in that video from Friday
that was the response to the player
video with the montage and a very
effective message for the owners to hide
behind Goodell that's one of the reasons
why he makes so much money we've talked
about this before
he's a forty to fifty million dollar a
year pin cushion so the owners might
hide behind the curtain and not suffer
the PR consequences from their policies
actions decisions behavior whatever the
Commissioner is the one who has to do it
and again the world has shifted on its
axis and this moment it requires
something more it requires more and more
owners to say what Goodell said and
ultimately to match what the players
wanted and to come out and address these
issues and say not just it's okay if you
choose to protest we support you we urge
you to make a conscientious decision as
to whether or not you're gonna stand sit
kneel or whatever during the national
anthem and we support you whatever that
decision is that's what owners need to
say and we know from experience that's
the last thing Jerry Jones wants to say
no well you know that's what I think
Richard Sherman is talking about you
know you can make a blanket statement as
the leading and Roger Goodell and all
that
you know teams and owners took their own
you know personal approach how to handle
this the first time around so of course
we see how passionate these players are
and I do want to recognize Leonard
fournette first off I mean unbelievable
von Miller
I've been around Vaughn a few times that
they don't get it they don't make him
any nicer of humans around I mean he's
just such a great guy and really shown
unbelievable leadership in some tough
situations here so I really want to
applaud them but you know at the very
least what guys like that von Miller
Leonard fournette Richard Sherman the
rest of the league is looking at and
going okay listen we heard a nice
statement by Roger Goodell I think most
players still would like to like it to
have been stronger they also what I
think would have liked it to be a little
bit more timely or quicker of a response
or statement from the NFL but the second
thing is yeah if you're a player in the
NFL right now and especially an
african-american player you want to know
the guy that's signing your checks the
guy that you know men you're thinking I
want to play for this team and maybe
sign my next contract and stay here for
a lot is in the fight with you I mean
those are just basic human principles
hey the guy I know that's my friend that
comes down and tells me how great I am
and all that wait does he really think
those things does he really support us
and I think Richard Sherman's point is
spot-on and I think again yeah Roger
Goodell is the Commissioner but these
owners are leaders in a lot bigger way
they lead organizations they lead other
big companies and of course we know
because of their financial you know
background and history and everything
like that that these are the real people
with power that can make things happen
make phone calls and really you know put
a lot towards getting the movement going
in a better faster you know financial
direction whatever it may be and I think
Richard Sherman's spot-on there here's
the bottom line Jerry Jones is the owner
to whom President Trump said a couple of
years ago you can't beat me on this
issue
of standing during the anthem it's a
winning issue for me I'm going to keep
coming at you they've reached a truce
kind of an awkward ceasefire that had
held until recently and I think one of
the reasons why we haven't heard from
Jerry Jones he doesn't want to inflame
that situation which has been
resurrected over the past few days
starting on drew Brees the the president
has gone after Roger Goodell and
yesterday this went on notice because
there was another tweet from the
president that caused a hell of a lot
more of an uproar than this one but he
retweeted this quote from match slap
Donald Trump retweeted this I will never
buy another NFL ticket until they go
back to playing football and stop
dividing America that was the retweet so
the fight is there I mean it's like what
do they call that the pot calling the
tea kettle black what is that I mean
that's a bunch of crap that really I
don't even know what what Ash lappy that
guy is get him out of here we worked we
worked very carefully to hold the show
within a certain parameter and well
Chris at least she didn't make me
nervous about whether or not you're
gonna jump over the line you just went
ahead and did it with both feet the
point is this
they don't want this fight with the
president if they can avoid it not they
some of the owners don't want it now
the Commissioner may not care drew brees
may not care the rest of the fans may
not care but the owners are the ones who
I think or at least for now trying to
plot a way to balance these competing
interests and that may be one of the
reasons why they're being quiet so good
point by Richard Sherman and fair for
people to say where are the owners on
this especially the ones who are the
first to grab a microphone when anything
of any remote interest comes up and we
know Jerry Jones is usually at the front
of that line
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports